hallo leute ich erzähle euch heute eine
kleine geschichte vor ungefähr einem
jahr habe ich eine e mail von einem
typen namens jeremy bekommen
wir sind apple tv studios die sich
später dem matching technologie happy to
be here moore baut ihr herr board
meeting hat auch auf extreme greetings
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
dann haben wir uns in unserem büro in
berlin getroffen und jeremy erzählte uns
seine geschichte er war vor drei jahren
aus new york nach berlin gezogen und
versuchte seither deutsch zu lernen
aber irgendwie war er mit allen methoden
die er ausprobierte unzufrieden
es waren weder authentisch noch wirklich
effektiv ein privat tut aber viel zu
teuer und youtube videos waren zwar cool
aber irgendwie nicht interaktiv genug
seine idee war es hingegen alle vorteile
von diesen verschiedenen ressourcen
miteinander zu kombinieren und eine ganz
neue art von sprach lernplattform zu
bauen
eine die videos hat aber in der jedes
einzelne wort anklickbar ist und bei
denen der fokus auf dem sprechen liegt
und nicht nur auf dem zu hören
sie zeigte mir die aktuelle version
seiner software und ich sagte bislang
sei sie ja in den nächsten wochen und
monaten verbrachten wir immer mehr zeit
damit inhalte und ein curriculum für sie
lenkt zu entwickeln um alle themen
abzudecken schrieben wir szenen um die
verschiedenen grammatik themen möglichst
witzig zu demonstrieren
dann haben wir diese szenen mit unseren
freunden und zuschauern verfilmt nur ein
zimmer seid ihr verrückt was für eine
party ist das eine deutsche party über
500 von unseren zuschauern haben ceiling
bereits getestet und uns in den letzten
monaten wichtiges feedback gegeben dass
wir in die software mit aufgenommen
haben und heute freuen wir uns
wahnsinnig euch die ergebnisse unserer
arbeit zeigen zu können
ihr seht jetzt wie jeremy euch die seite
demonstriert los geht's
[Musik]
dann sagte ich ihr meinen
sie machte große augen machte
[Musik]
wir freuen uns wahnsinnig wenn ihr jetzt
auch sieht menge ausprobiert kommt
vorbei und probiert es aus den link
findet ihr hier unter unserem youtube
video
wir freuen uns auf euer feedback
bis gleich bei sealink
[Musik]